bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur Public Sénat voici le programme de
votre après-midi dans un instant édition
de Michel Sapin ministre des Finances et
de Christian et carte secrétaire d'État
chargé du budget les deux ministres sont
entendus par la commission des finances
du Sénat sur le collectif budgétaire il
a été présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres analyse et des cryptages à
suivre de notre journaliste tome 3
à 19h pour 24 heures Sénat le journal
nous reviendrons sur la réforme
ferroviaire contestée par les cheminots
qui entendent reconduire pour 24 heures
la grève
en sciences publiques les sénateurs des
battent des conclusions de la mission
d'information du Sénat sur le sport
professionnel et les collectivités
territoriales je vous propose d'écouter
à ce sujet Michel Savin sénatori MP de
l'Isère il nous parle de la
particularité du modèle français
nulle part en Europe le sport
professionnel rentable celui qui draine
des sommes considérables et qui
fonctionnent comme une véritable
activité économique ne fait l'objet de
subventions publiques la France se
distingue en cela clairement de la
pratique européenne ce qui pose question
s'étend de disette budgétaire
deuxième constat
concernant les stades un mouvement
important est à l'oeuvre en Europe
notamment depuis la Coupe du monde 2006
en Allemagne qui s'illustre par la
construction de nouveaux stades dont les
clubs sont les propriétaires cela remet
en cause le modèle français de propriété
municipales du stade nous avons constaté
en Allemagne et encore plus en
Angleterre que la responsabilité sociale
des clubs était considérable
chaque saison ce sont ainsi près de 40
millions de livres sterling qui sont
consacrés des projets socio-éducatifs
par les clubs de la première ligue au
travers de leur fonds de dotation en
France
seul 5 clubs de football sont dotés de
fondation ou de fonds de dotation et
leur budget ce chiffre à 400 000 euros
tout au plus
sur ce plateau bonjour Thom bonjour
David alors dans un instant je le disais
on va suivre l'audition des ministres
des Finances c'est du secrétaire d'État
à charger du budget Christian Eckert
entendu tous les deux par la commission
des finances du scénario une audition
c'est ce qui s'inscrit dans un contexte
de fronde à l'Assemblée nationale mais
aussi au Sénat ou l'appel descend est en
train de faire tâche d'huile et lui
aussi là ils ne sont pas 100 mais ils
ont tout de même 9 9 rondeurs qui osent
affronter l'exécutif sur le budget sur
qui disent non à l'austérité qui disent
non aux coupes budgétaire parmi eux
notamment Gaëtan Gorce ou encore
Marie-Noël linman bien sûr qui
représente l'aile de gauche de la gauche
ici au Sénat mais aussi le sénateur Yves
Rome tous veulent tirer les
enseignements de la double défaite des
municipales et des européennes on va
tout de suite écouter
ivre rom
nous concitoyens lors de ces deux
consultations et surtout de la dernière
on manifesté très largement se désespoir
ce manque de confiance dans la politique
et les politiques qui sont conduites et
donc notre rôle de parlementaire et de
veiller à ce que les politiques
nécessaires si vous voulez de lutte
contre les déficits ne conduisent pas à
l'impasse car vous connaissez la
prophétie du magasin du médecin de
Molière à force de saigner le malade on
peut le sauver le tueur
que nous avons donc rencontré hier avant
une réunion avec ces fameux sénateurs
frondeurs alors que réclame-t-il un
soutien à l'investissement des
collectivités locales au pouvoir d'achat
des ménages les plus modestes et à la
modernisation des infrastructures leur
objectif se coordonner avec les 100 de
l'Assemblée justement pour déposer des
amendements prochains budget et
rectificatifs bref cet après-midi elle
est ministres du Budget et des Finances
qui vont être auditionnés par la
commission des finances sur le budget
rectificatif faut avoir quelques soucis
avec la droite mais aussi avec la gauche
merci beaucoup Tam alors justement on va
prendre tout de suite à la direction de
la salle Médicis où se déroule cette
audition c'est Philippe Marigny le
président de la commission des finances
qui s'exprime en l'écoute
introductive que je me permets de vous
de vous soumettre
et bien entendu dans le cours de la
discussion nous reviendrons sur ces
sujets et dans les médias nous écoutons
avec attention votre présentation de ce
projet choix de finance rectificative
pour 2014 donc c'est d'abord Monsieur
Michel Sapin je pense
puis sans doute Monsieur Christian
Eckert et l'un et l'autre ensuite
s'attacheront certainement à répondre
aux questions du rapporteur général puis
des membres de la de la commission
sachant monsieur le ministre que cette
audition devrait durer de l'ordre d'une
heure écart si elle en veut pouvoir
tenir compte des impératifs des uns et
des autres je vous en prie merci
infiniment monsieur le Président
Monsieur rapporteur général mesdames
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
merci aussi de votre perspicacité nous
allons effectivement parler tous les
deux je vais essayer de fixer les grands
enjeux de cette loi de finance
rectificative que vous appeliez de vos
vœux voilà un de vos vœux en tout cas
qui est
exaucé et puis bien sûr Christian Ecker
qui connaît particulièrement bien
l'ensemble de ces
débats caractères budgétaires et ces
données budgétaires voudra apporter sa
pierre précieuse à notre à notre débat
ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative c'est ce que j'ai
l'habitude d'appeler l'acte 1 de la mise
en oeuvre du pacte de responsabilité et
de solidarité
qui commence par des économies
supplémentaires cette année et qui se
poursuivra et c'est là où il conviendra
bien entendu de regarder déjà la loi de
financement pour 2015 et la loi de
programmation qui est annuelle
2015-2016-2017 c'est 50 milliards
d'économies 50 milliards d'euros
d'économies étant indispensable à la
mise en oeuvre dans de bonnes conditions
de ce pacte de responsabilité d'une part
pour financer les diminutions de
cotisations et d'impôts dont je vais
parler au profit aussi bien des
entreprises que des ménages et d'autre
part pour continuer la diminution de
notre déficit et la maîtrise de notre
dette c'est au fond pour répondre à une
de vos premières questions monsieur le
Président ce cette loi de finance dans
sa partie économique puisque nous allons
faire 4 milliards d'économies au total
et Christian Eckert présentera en
particulier le 1 milliard 6 d'annulation
de crédit budgétaire 2014 que ce texte
c'est notre réponse à la demande en
particulier ou la recommandation de
recommandations de la Commission
européenne un effort additionnel a été
souhaité il était nécessaire compte tenu
du fait que l'année dernière en 2013
nous avons totalement et complètement
respecté les objectifs de dépenses même
légèrement en dessous mais compte tenu
d'une croissance faible nous n'avons pas
atteint nos objectifs de recettes ils
convenait donc en 2014 de diminuer la
marche à franchir entre 2014 et 2015 en
termes de maîtrise de nos déficits
le avec le projet de loi de financement
exclusif de la sécurité sociale qui sera
donc déposée mercredi prochain nous
engageons la mise en oeuvre des annonces
qui ont été faites par le Président de
la République certains disent qui ont
été faites il y a plusieurs mois le
rythme travail gouvernemental et le
rythme parlementaire ne permet pas de
mettre des programmes de cette nature de
cette ampleur en place en l'espace
quelques de quelques jours ces annonces
avaient été faites en début d'année
elles avaient été confirmées par le
Premier ministre ici même d'ailleurs
lors de la déclaration de politique
générale elle avait aussi trouvé sa
traduction dans le pacte de stabilité
qui avait fait l'objet ici même d'un
débat et qui avait fait l'objet d'un
vote avec une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale l'objectif est évidemment de
renforcer notre politique en faveur de
la croissance en faveur de l'emploi avec
des mesures de soutien de compétitivité
et il convient d'adopter dès à présent
des mesures qui permettront d'alléger la
pression fiscale et sociale sur les
ménages à revenus les plus modestes en
donnant de la visibilité sur les mesures
à l'horizon 2017 et en inscrivant dans
la loi dès maintenant les mesures du
pacte 2014-2015 j'assiste sur ce point
vous trouverez d'ailleurs dans un
document j'espère qu'il est à votre
disposition qui est le dossier de presse
présenté à l'occasion de ce pdfr 2014 en
dernière page une mise en perspective
sur quatre années 2014 mais surtout 2015
2016-2017 de l'ensemble du pack de
respecter j'insiste sur ce point car
c'est la première fois que l'ensemble du
pack de responsabilité est ainsi
présenté année après année mesure après
mesure avec les quantums en termes de
diminution de cotisation ou de
diminution d'impôts au bénéfice des
entreprises c'est indispensable parce
que les entreprises ont besoin d'une
visibilité
de comprendre quelle est la stratégie du
gouvernement je l'espère la stratégie du
Parlement dans la mise en oeuvre de ce
pack de responsabilité et c'est donc
cette visibilité qui est ainsi affichée
elle est affichée aussi dans les exposés
des motifs du texte qui vous est
présenté le choix par ailleurs a été
fait de proposer dans l'un et l'autre
texte finance financement de la sécurité
sociale les mesures applicables
évidemment en 2014 c'était indispensable
de le faire dès maintenant mais aussi je
vous irons attentifs les mesures
applicables en 2015 de manière à ce que
dès le mois de juillet les entreprises
comme les ménages connaissent la
totalité des mesures quantum des mesures
les modalités des mesures qui seront
mises en oeuvre et dont elles pourront
tenir compte pour prendre éventuellement
dès maintenant un certain nombre de
décision en termes d'investissement ou
en termes de préparation d'embauche au
vu de la certitude que ces mesures
seront mises en place dès le 1er janvier
de l'année prochaine
le PLF prévoit
dans la mise en oeuvre du pacte deux
mesures d'une part l'allègement d'impôt
sur le revenu qui sera effectif dès
l'automne prochain pour les ménages les
plus modestes vous en connaissez les
grandes lignes une réduction d'impôts
réduction d'impôts de 350 euros 700
euros pour un couple au bénéfice des
contribuables dont le revenu fiscal de
référence est inférieur à 1,1 SMIC que
ce revenu fiscal soit dû à des salaires
ou qui soit dû à des retraites ou tout
autre revenu ce sont dès lors 3700
000 foyers fiscaux qui bénéficieront de
la mesure dont un million 900
000 dont un million 900 000 qui ne
verseront aucun impôt au Trésor public
du fait de cette mesure l'impact de
cette réduction d'impôts sera
automatiquement intégré au sol de
l'impôt sur le revenu qui sera adressé
au contribuable à la mi-septembre 2014
sans démarche particulière de leur part
ce sont donc à peu près un million
200000 foyers qui s'étaient vu intégrer
dans l'impôt sur le revenu au cours des
deux dernières années je parle de 2012
et de 2013 du fait de mesures prises par
les uns ou par les autres parfois avec
un effet retard considérable puisqu'on
voit encore en 2014 des effets de mesure
qui ont pu être votés en 2011 c'est ça
aussi la lenteur si je puis dire du
train fiscal et de ses conséquences des
foyers qui n'avaient pas vu leur revenu
augmenter mais que du fait de telle ou
telle mesure rentrer dans l'impôt avec
toutes les conséquences dommageables que
ça peut avoir pour elle pour ces
familles ou pour ses foyers donc ce sont
un million 200000 à peu près qui vont
sortir de l'impôt et c'est ce qui nous
permettra par ailleurs d'éviter qui est
aux alentours de 0,6 ou 07 à 600 à 700
mille foyers nouveaux qui rentrent dans
la peau à l'automne prochain c'est donc
un effort tout à fait considérable pour
éviter ce qui était perçu par beaucoup
comme une forme d'injustice quand votre
revenu augmente il peut arriver il est
même souhaitable qu'à un moment donné on
se mette à payer des impôts comme dirait
l'autre c'est plutôt bon signe mais
lorsque votre revenu n'augmente pas et
que vous mettez à rentrer dans l'impôt
il y a là quelque chose qui est
considéré comme parfaitement
incompréhensible et c'est à cela que
nous voulons remédier au total ce sera
un allégement de 1 milliard 100 d'euros
au bénéfice de ces ménages de cet
automne nous avons eu jusque au dernier
moment à tenir compte de la vie du
Conseil d'État pour ceux qui avaient
regardé les choses attentivement pour
éviter un effet de seuil trop important
il y a donc un certain lissage qui
permet d'éviter qui est un effet trop
brutal due à une mesure de cette nature
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale complètement cette
mesure par un allègement de cotisation
salariale pour l'épaisseur personne qui
ont un salaire compris entre 1 et 1,3
SMIC c'est allégement représentera 500
euros par an à compter de 2015 dès le
1er janvier 2015 pour les personnes qui
sont payées au SMIC soit un allègement
de 2 milliards 500 millions d'euros
d'autre part le PLF prévoit que la
suppression de la contribution
exceptionnelle d'impôt sur les sociétés
à la charge des très grandes entreprises
interviendra non pas en 2015 comme
c'était prévu jusqu'à présent mais en
2016 cette prorogation
permettra de maximiser l'ampleur des
mesures du pacte ciblé en 2015 sur
l'emploi et les investissements au
travers d'allègement qui vont concerner
les basses salaires et qui vont beaucoup
concerner les TPE les PME et les ETI
donc une volonté de faire en sorte que
2015 soit si je puis dire l'année
prioritairement tournée vers ces petites
et moyennes entreprises vers les
entreprises de taille intermédiaires
pour lesquelles l'effet en termes
d'emploi peut être le plus rapide mais
tout en inscrivant dans la durée
2016-2017 et la fin de cette surtaxe sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés pour les très
grandes entreprises et des baisses de
cotisation qui iront au-delà de 1,6 SMIC
et jusqu'à
3,5 SMIC
ces mesures qui sont proposées dans le
cadre du plfs consisteront donc en un
allègement de cotisations patronales
entre 1 et 1 sismiques pour 4,5
milliards d'euros avec ce qui sera très
spectaculaire et très compréhensible par
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise à 0
chargeurs au niveau du SMIC une seule
ligne avec écrit 0 au niveau du SMIC en
terme de charge d'URSSAF à ceux qui
disent ça coûte cher même vos SMIC non
ce sera 0 et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui sera très facile à comprendre
et très lisible il y aura un allègement
de cotisation des indépendants pour 1
milliard d'euros et il y aura un premier
abattement pour un milliard d'euros de
la contribution sociale de solidarité
des sociétés profitant à toutes les
entreprises mais plus particulièrement
là aussi au PME et aux ETI puisque deux
tiers des entreprises ne paieront plus
la C3S
à l'horizon 2017 le gouvernement mais il
annonce dès maintenant vous proposera de
compléter ces mesures par un allégement
de cotisation patronale entre 1,6 et 3 5
SMIC par la suppression complète de la
C3S par l'amorce d'un mouvement de
baisse du taux d'impôt sur les sociétés
avec la dispuition de la contribution
exceptionnelle en 2016 je vous l'ai déjà
dit puis une diminution du taux d'IS en
2017 qui atteindrait alors
progressivement 28% en 2020
le gouvernement a donc pour priorité de
soutenir croissance et emploi mais
également c'est le deuxième élément
qu'il faut prendre en compte à la fois
dans le pacte de stabilité et dans ce
projet de loi de finance rectificatif a
aussi comme ambition d'assainir
progressivement les finances publiques
depuis 2012 tant le déficit nominal que
le déficit structurel ont diminué
régulièrement à compter de 2015
l'amélioration des finances publiques se
fera uniquement par des économies sur la
dépense et par la mise en oeuvre de ce
programme d'économie de 50 milliards
d'euros qui a été présenté dans le
programme de stabilité le projet de loi
de finance rectificatif propose une
première traduction de ce plan
d'économie avec le report de la
revalorisation des aides au logement
financées par l'État bien sûr la loi de
financement la sécurité sociale traduira
aussi un certain nombre d'économies
l'effort qui est ainsi demandé sera
compensée parce que pour les
bénéficiaires du RSA la revalorisation
de 2% prévu dans le cas du plan pauvreté
et maintenu et parce que pour les
salariés qui sont payés au SMIC par
l'allègement des cotisations salariales
que j'ai évoqué les 500 euros de gains
par an soit 42 euros par mois qui
permettra de compenser et bien au-delà
sur les ménages les plus modestes les
inconvénients d'un d'une non
augmentation des prestations en question
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale proposera le report de
la revalorisation d'un son d'autres
prestations sociales les pensions de
base pour les retraités touchant de
petites retraites dont le montant
cumulant la retraite de base et la
retraite complémentaire est inférieure à
1200 euros et les minima sociaux
resteront indexées sur l'inflation les
économies attendues de ces mesures
seront constatées pour leur plus grande
part en 2015 le gouvernement propose par
ailleurs d’engager je vous le disais dès
le début dès 2014 un effort
supplémentaire d'économie d'un montant
de 4 milliards d'euros ces économies
supplémentaires sécuriseront donc la
teinte d'un déficit de 3,8% du PIB en
2014 elle permet aussi d'apporter une
première réponse à ce que vous allez
vous-même souligner monsieur le
Président l'enclenchement de la
procédure dite de correction des écarts
prévus par la loi organique du 17
décembre 2012
juridiquement cette prise en compte
aurait dû être faite en PLF 2015
toutefois le gouvernement l'anticipe dès
ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative d'assainissement des
finances publiques est une priorité qui
doit être amplifiée dès maintenant
le projet de loi de finance rectif
prévoit un montant d'annulation de
crédit de 1,6 milliards d'euros dont un
milliard d'euros de crédit frais je
pense que Christian Eckert vous donnera
davantage des étages de détails sur ces
annulations d'autres mesures d'économie
en gestion concernent le report de
revalorisation de certaines prestations
sociales de moindre dépenses à hauteur
de 1,1 milliard d'euros sur la sécurité
sociale qui découle de dépenses moins
élevées que prévu en 2013 et qui seront
pérennisés dans le cadre du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale de moindre dépense
aussi à hauteur de 600 millions
s'agissant de l'unédique qui découle
également de dépenses moindres que prévu
en 2013 voilà monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
que nous vous proposons vous nous avez
monsieur le Président interrogé sur deux
ou trois aspects de macroéconomie
deux points premièrement le niveau de
l'inflation prévu et d'autre part le
niveau de la croissance prévue sur ces
deux sujets comme disait quelqu'un les
prévisions sont toujours difficiles
surtout lorsque elle concerne l'avenir
chacun a pu s'y puis dire mesurer la
difficulté à quelques périodes que ce
soit mais je pense que si je regarde
comme vous je lis est très attentivement
la vie qui est celui du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques je lis que certes le
conseil et il a raison de le faire
considère que la prévision de croissance
à 1% que nous maintenons et plus
difficile à atteindre aujourd'hui dans
les conditions d'aujourd'hui que nous ça
pouvait être prévu au début de cette
année mais je le cite il considère que
cette prévision est
tout à fait atteignable dit qu'elle
n'est pas hors d'atteinte même si cette
prévision de croissance est
peut paraître aujourd'hui élevé la même
chose même remarque peut-être faite sur
le niveau de l'inflation j'aimerais au
fond conclure cette intervention en vous
disant de choses sommes dans une période
incertaine ou l'économie européenne
d'une manière générale à l'exception
peut-être de l'économie allemande
l'économie française de manière plus
particulière sont une forme
d'incertitude où les entreprises sont
certes sorties de cette trop longue
période cinq ans en dessous du niveau
qu'elles avaient atteintes en termes de
richesse en 2008 elles viennent tout
juste d'en sortir à la fin de l'année
2013 et elles sont dans une forme
d'hésitation et c'est face à cette forme
d'hésitation qu'il faut agir pour
essayer en quelque sorte de surmonter ce
scepticisme devant l'avenir et il y a
deux grands types de décisions qui ont
été prises ou sont en train nous vous le
proposons aujourd'hui d'être prise la
première c'est
celle que la Banque centrale européenne
a prise la Banque centrale européenne a
la semaine dernière pris un ensemble
d'éditions absolument considérables par
leur ampleur par leur nature comme je
crois rarement la Banque centrale
européenne n'avait plus en prendre les
taux d'intérêts ont encore baissé mais
surtout elle a pris des décisions pour
essayer de faire en sorte que le
financement d'être économique et en
particulier le financement des
entreprises soient plus fluide plus
simple et à des coûts moins élevés
qu'ils peuvent l'être aujourd'hui la
préoccupation de la Banque centrale
européenne c'est de lutter contre cette
trop faible inflation je reprends ces
termes elle ne prend pas le terme de
déflation peut-être y a-t-il un risque
mais en tous les cas elle veut lutter
contre une trop faible inflation pour
essayer de retrouver son objectif
européen qui est aux alentours de 2%.
nous avons nous mis un objectif qui est
inférieur à celui-ci supérieur à
l'inflation constatée donc nous pouvons
penser si la Banque centrale européenne
comme je le crois a pris les bonnes
décisions il y aura une petite élévation
du niveau des prix au cours des mois qui
viennent qui nous permettra d'être en
ligne avec ce que nous avons prévu il en
va de même de la question de la
croissance qui ne se décrète pas d'en
haut qui se constate ou qui se crée dans
les entreprises elles-mêmes dans le
tissu économique 1% si rien ne se
passait dans les mois qui viennent ça ne
sera pas possible à atteindre si comme
nous le pensons le cumul de la des
décisions de la Banque centrale
européenne avec tous ces effets y
compris par rapport au niveau de l'euro
en comparaison d'autres monnaies
internationales et si le pack de
responsabilité est voté avec cette
cohérence avec cette détermination avec
cette conviction oui je pense qu'il peut
y avoir ce déclic en termes de
croissance en termes de décision dans
les entreprises qui s'enclenchent et
c'est cela qui font de la stratégie la
cohérence elle peut être évidemment
disputée j'allais dire qu'elle peut être
disputée c'est là aussi le rôle du débat
démocratique mais c'est là la cohérence
profonde des propositions qui vous sont
faites la loi de financement la loi de
finance rectificative d'aujourd'hui est
vraiment le tout début de cette mise en
œuvre du pack de responsabilité première
acte il sera suivi la semaine prochaine
d'un autre texte que Marisol Touraine
aura l'occasion de venir présenter je
pense devant la commission des affaires
sociales mais vous serez certainement
saisi pour avis c'est tout cela qui crée
cette cohérence et qui doit nous
permettre de booster en quelque sorte
d'allumer les deux moteurs le moteur
européen Banque centrale européenne le
moteur français le pack de
responsabilité pour retrouver une
croissance indispensable à notre
économie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre de cette présentation luminaire
bien entendu nous n'oublions pas ni les
uns ni les autres que même si l'objectif
difficile à atteindre de 1% de
croissance
se vérifie il est insuffisant pour
entraîner des cons favorable sur le
marché de l'emploi soyons en effet bien
conscient alors j'ai donc le plaisir de
passer la parole à Christian Eckert et
je le ferai
mais je pense qu'il va traiter cela avec
précision comme toujours dans son exposé
et en pointant deux choses dans les
documents que nous avait remis et le
tableau d'ensemble qui est celui de la
page 33 n'est-ce pas du document projet
de loi de finance rectificatif pour 2014
fait apparaître en bas de colonne un
solde générale loi de finance initiale -
82,57 milliards d'euros n'est-ce pas et
situation nouvelle
-83,94 milliards d'euros donc ceci
veut-il dire que le déficit augmente
monsieur le secrétaire d'État de la loi
de finance initiale à cette loi de
finances rectif ensuite et à l'État a
nous avons les estimations de recettes
et ce sujet a retenu tout notre intérêt
dans l'examen de la loi de règlement
avec vous-même il y a quelques jours et
nous avons débattu d'ailleurs de manière
tout à fait approfondie en particulier
de la question du coefficient
d'élasticité qui a été constaté en 2013
et qui est exceptionnel qui est tout à
fait anormal dans les séries telles que
nous avons pu les analyser jusqu'ici or
ici nous avons
des chiffres en diminution par rapport à
la loi de finance initiale et sans doute
ses diminutions
intègrent-elles à la fois des mesures
nouvelles donc ce que vous proposez dans
le texte et sans doute aussi peut-être
mais vous allez nous le dire une
actualisation une réévaluation des
perspectives de recettes
à droit constant je vois impôt sur le
revenu - 3 milliards 184 millions impose
sur les sociétés moins 4 milliards 293
millions taxes sur la valeur ajoutée
moins 1 milliard 354 millions voilà
j'en reste là de ces de ces de ces
questions simplement destinées à
éclairer
la compréhension des membres de la
commission mais je suis certain monsieur
le secrétaire d'État que vous allez nous
apporter à cet égard tous les éléments
d'appréciation indispensables et le
plaisir vous passez la parole
merci merci monsieur le Président je
m'efforcerai d'apporter le maximum de
réponses à vos questions précises et
sans avoir forcément réponse à tout
permettez-moi d'abord de compléter la
réponse déjà fort large pendant la
présentation déjà forme large de Michel
Sapin qu'il l'a fait à la fois sur le
champ puisqu'il a traité du PLF et du
PFR SS et il a fait aussi dans le temps
puisqu'il a évoqué des mesures 2014 mais
ses talents jusqu'à 2017 pour pour
certaines d'entre elles je me
concentrerai sur l'aspect du cadrage
budgétaire du PFR ce qui permettra je
crois monsieur le Président de répondre
à vos questions
oui le projet de loi revoit le déficit
de l'État en hausse de 1,4 milliards
d'euros par rapport à la prévision de la
loi de finances initiale
à savoir 83,9 milliards d'euros si nous
y retranchons le programme
d'investissement d'avenir c'est de
prévisions s'établit donc à 71,9
milliards d'euros mais j'observe puisque
nous avons eu l'occasion de parler de la
loi de règlement qu'il était en 2013 de
74,9 milliards d'euros c'est à dire que
même s'il est en augmentation par
rapport à la loi de finances initiale il
est en diminution de près de 3 milliards
par rapport à l'exécution 2013
nous étions à 148 milliards d'euros
nous avons donc en gros divisé par deux
le déficit du budget de l'État
cette prévision de diminution
et donc maintenu même si par rapport à
la loi de finance initiale peut-être que
la loi de finances rectificative de fin
d'année pourtant d'autres modifications
mais elle est donc maintenue pour
cette année en recette la prévision est
revue à la baisse vous l'avez signalé de
5,3 milliards d'euros par rapport à la
prévision initiale des moins-values ont
été constatés en exécution en 2013 mais
c'est moins valu monsieur le Président
vous en souvenez ont été constatés dans
le courant de l'année 2013 ont été
constatés même après la fin de l'année
2013 puisque l'exécution est par
définition connue après la clôture de
l'exercice
et il est je crois de bonnes gestion et
de bonnes prudence que d'en faire le
constat et de revoir à la baisse dans
une loi de finance rectificative les
prévisions de recettes
elles ont été ajustées comme tel
le gouvernement propose
de répercuter sur la prévision pour 2014
la totalité des moins-values constater
en 2013 c'est le cas pour l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est le cas pour l'impôt sur les
sociétés en revanche lorsqu'il y a eu
des plus-values d'exécution en 2013 le
principe est d'une répercuter qu'une
partie de la meilleure exécution ainsi
vous souvenez qu'en fin d'année 2013
nous avions constaté une plus-value de
TVA de 0,6 milliards d'euros en
comptabilité budgétaire et de 1,5
milliards d'euros en comptabilité
nationale par prudence nous ne retenons
qu'une partie de cette plus-value en
réduisant la TV à la hausse seulement
0,5 milliards d'euros
outre ses effets bases la principale
information nouvelle depuis la dernière
prévision et le rendement plus important
des recettes tirées du stdr vous savez
le service de traitement des
déclarations rectificatives ceux qui
mettent en conformité leur situation
fistale lorsqu'ils avaient des avoir
détenus à l'étranger non déclaré nous y
avions prévu une recette de 850 millions
d'euros en loi de finance initiale il
ressort de l'activité de ce service sur
les cinq premiers mois de l'année que
cette recette sera sans doute supérieure
de 1 milliard d'euros par rapport à la
prévision initiale ce surplus de
ressources a une incidence sur l'impôt
sur le revenu sur l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune et sur les droits de
mutation à titre gratuit
concernant les dépenses l'article
d'équilibre retrace deux évolutions
d'une part la charge de la dette est
revue à la baisse de 1,8 milliards
d'euros ce moindre coût de la charge
d'intérêt traduit notamment les bas les
taux pardon exceptionnellement bas
auquel l'état emprunte donc ce cette
économie traduit la confiance des
créanciers de l'État dans sa signature
d'autre part le gouvernement propose
comme cela vient d'être indiqué par le
ministre des Finances d'annuler pour 1,6
milliards d'euros de crédit
ceci représente la passion de l'État à
l'effort de 4 milliards d'euros
d'économies supplémentaires pour 2014
je vais vous en donner le détail
mais il répond à votre préoccupation qui
avait été de dire quelles sont les
mesures correctrices que l'État est
disposé à mettre en œuvre suite aux
différents avis notamment à la procédure
de correction des écarts qui est mise en
œuvre ces 4 milliards d'euros se
décomposent donc en 1,6 milliards
d'euros d'économies sur le budget de
l'État j'y reviendrai
1,1 milliard d'euros sur le budget de la
Sécurité sociale à savoir 800 millions
d'euros qui tiennent compte là aussi de
la meilleure de la sous-exécution des
dépenses d'assurance maladie pour 2013
nous reprenons en base 2014 la moindre
exécution de 2013
augmenter donc ces 800 millions de 300
millions d'euros
issus de la non revalorisation d'un
certain nombre de prestations en 2014
qui donne bien 1,1 milliard d'euros
600 millions sont inscrits au titre des
économies fait par faite si j'ose dire
par les partenaires sociaux sur la
gestion de l'Unédic 300 millions d'euros
concernent le font national d'action
sociale là aussi en pérennisant les
économies réalisées en 2013 et 400
millions d'euros sont constatés en
sous-exécution prévue du paysa c'est une
moindre dépense dont d'ailleurs je pense
que cette commission à l'habitude
régulièrement chaque année
je reviens à l'instant sur le 1,6
milliards d'annulation de dépenses de
l'État un milliard d'euros
concerne des annulations si j'ose dire
de crédit frais c'est une première je
crois qu'il est exceptionnel je crois
même unique qu'un collectif budgétaire
annule des crédits
ces crédits sont annulés sur l'ensemble
des ministères vous en avez la liste
page 15 dans le dossier de presse et
bien sûr dans le document détaillé
et si j'ose utiliser une formule non pas
consister à utiliser
un rabot elles ont constitué
elles ont été issues de l'utilisation de
notre cerveau c'est à dire que nous
avons balayé avec l'ensemble des
ministres et l'ensemble
oui on a plutôt tendance à penser qu'un
rabot d'habitude c'est un peu stupide et
uniforme
cerveau toute métaphores assez assez
travers
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que nous
avons eu un dialogue avec l'ensemble des
ministres pour évaluer en cours d'année
quelles étaient les lignes qui pouvaient
être
sous-exécuté à la fin de l'année au mois
de mai où nous avons réalisé cet
exercice qu'ils ont fait avril début mai
il y avait des as déjà des
sous-exécutions prévisibles nous avons
évidemment pas pu agir sur des dépenses
du titre 2 ma salariale qui en général
va sauve quelques exceptions sont des
dépenses quasi incompressibles et nous
avons tenu compte de l'évolution des
dépenses de prestations qui souvent
suivent des situations sociales dont
l'évolution et là encore difficilement
maîtrisable et donc vous en avez le
détail à la page 15
et si vous additionnez tous les chiffres
que je viens de rappeler vous en arrivez
à 4 milliards d'économies sur l'ensemble
des budgets
mais ce n'est pas ça la justification de
ce collectif budgétaire il faudra
revenir à l'instant de ce président sur
votre propos liminaire où vous disiez
que le l'an dernier vous aviez réclamé
un corps et accri une loi de finance
rectificative
je pense que c'est pas par souci de
stakhanovisme budgétaire
nous sommes des drogués au travail et
puis on nous a dit passé il n'y a rien à
voir oui mais monsieur le Président si
je pouvais aller au bout de mon propos
vous vous
entendons-nous bien un collectif
budgétaire n'est indispensable
que pour prendre de nouvelles mesures
fiscales
si il s'agit de moins dépenser
nul n'est besoin de collectif budgétaire
tous les gouvernements et j'ose dire
particulièrement les deux derniers si je
compte que celui-ci serait le deuxième
ont utilisé des procédures de gel voire
de surgel en cours d'année en 2012 2
milliards de surgels ont été décidés
immédiatement et nous pouvons à tout
moment décider de geler des dépenses
budgétaires nul n'est besoin de
collectif pour le faire quant à
l'information du Parlement et à la prise
en compte de l'évolution des paramètres
des constats ou à la réactualisation
d'un certain nombre de données
là encore nul n'est besoin de loi de
finances rectificatives
nous avons démontré l'année dernière
durant l'année nous avons pointé
régulièrement à chaque discussion avec
le Parlement à l'occasion de chaque
texte y compris les programmes de
stabilité ou autre document à
destination de l'Europe ou à destination
de la Cour des comptes ou à dessiner
nations de bien d'autres et nous avons
évoqué longuement vous le rappeliez ce
sujet lors de notre dernière notre
dernier entrevue donc qu'est-ce qui
justifie et très bien si vous en
réjouissez ce collectif budgétaire ce
sont effectivement les mesures fiscales
et notamment la mesure fiscale en
direction des ménages qui est incluse
sinon nous aurons pu nous passer de
collectif budgétaires
et cette mesure fiscale monsieur le
Président j'insiste sur un point
pardonnez-moi ce clin d'oeil à l'air
rétroactive
j'observe d'ailleurs que personne ne se
plaint aujourd'hui comprenne une mesure
fiscale rétroactive pour un milliard 100
de dire qu'il y a eu d'autres mesures
fiscales rétroactives dont personne ne
sait plein notamment sur les plus-values
des valeurs
immobilières ou des valeurs mobilières
passons c'est c'était l'an dernier donc
ce qui disent qu'il ne faut jamais de
rétroactivité qui veulent même se loto
interdire
non mais j'ai entendu quelques idées de
cette nature dans une autre assemblée
dit dans une autre astuce une autre
assemblée mais venant d'un côté de
l'hémicycle que vous connaissez donc
un milliard un milliard 100 dans une
mesure collective dans une mesure
correctrice sur l'impôt sur le revenu
chat sympa la largement détaillée je ne
reviendrai pas c'est ça qui a rendu ce
collectif nécessaire
au final
au-delà du milliard d'annulation de
crédit frais il y a 600 millions
j'arrondis les chiffres d'annulation
anticipée de la réserve de précaution ce
qui je crois est de bonne gestion il
nous reste 6,8 milliards dans ce qui est
convenu d'appeler la réserve de
précaution ce qui je pense nous
permettra de faire face aux aléas de
gestion et donc de tenir l'autorisation
parlementaire que nous sollicitons
nous en conclusion ce président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
sommes prêt bien entendu à répondre et à
compléter toutes questions qui
pourraient vous venir ce projet de loi
prouve qu'il est possible de réduire le
déficit public en maîtrisant la dépense
je rappelle 4 milliards d'euros
d'économies sont dégagés en cours
d'année gouvernement tant poursuivre ces
efforts au projet de loi de finance 2015
avec la mise en oeuvre du plan
d'économie de 50 milliards d'euros que
nous sommes en train de préparer
d'arrache-pied pas facile mais nous
présenterons les choses très
prochainement
j'ajoute que
nous restons ouverts un travail
notamment avec votre commission pour
pérenniser la mesure
d'aménagement qui prend cette année la
forme de réduction d'impôts je pense
qu'il serait de bonnes pratiques que
cette réduction d'impôts en termes en
tout cas de Quantum de volume soit
travailler pour qu'en loi de finance
initiale nous ayons une entrée plus
souple plus juste
sur les premières tranches d'impôt sur
le revenu nous avons fait le choix par
souci d'efficacité de rapidité pour
quelques raisons techniques aussi
contenu du ce moment de l'année où
matériellement les rôles sont déjà en
cours de préparation on choisit la forme
d'une réduction d'impôt je pense qu'il y
aurait lieu de travailler avec tous ceux
qui voudraient bien aussi appeler sur
une mesure correctrice de ce qui est
convenu d'appeler le bas de barème le
rapport de Dominique Lefebvre et de
François hauvigne pose un certain nombre
de principes de pistes qu'il me paraît
utile de travailler voilà j'anticipe
donc sur les débats de l'automne mais
nous savons que dans les semaines qui
viennent nous avons devant nous de beaux
débats en perspective et puisque vous
m'avez donné aimablement la parole je
vous la rend monsieur le Président vous
remercions et bien monsieur le
secrétaire d'État monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup de toutes ces
explications et en effet
réjouissons-nous par avance des débats
qui sont devant nous et qui nous
permettront de confronter nos analyses
nos idées et de le faire bien sûr de
part et d'autre espérons-le dans le
souci du bien commun alors monsieur le
rapporteur général à vous d'interroger
les ministres
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les mini chers collègues cela
fait bientôt deux ans nous étions réunis
ici au Sénat pour le projet de loi de
finances rectificatif
l'exercice 2012 qui faisait suite à
l'élection présidentielle chacun se
souvient que les thèmes de l'emploi et
de la croissance avaient été très
largement au cœur des discussions et
ceci avait motivé je crois un certain
nombre d'orientation qui avait été
introduites déjà dans le PLF et des
ajustements budgétaires indispensables
puisque la situation qui avait été
transmise à la nouvelle équipe
comportait au niveau budgétaire un
certain nombre de
trous qu'il fallait combler ce qui a
conduit à rechercher les recettes
nouvelles pour cela
mais
derrière ce PLFR on a eu monsieur Miss
des finances satisfaction de voir que le
gouvernement avait pris à bras le corps
la question de l'emploi avec la mise en
place du cice dès l'automne après le
rapport Gallois la création de la BPI
dont chacun reconnaît aujourd'hui
qu'elle a une action tout à fait
déterminée sur le terrain auprès de nos
entreprises et bien entendu la mise en
oeuvre d'une politique industrielle
qui est aujourd'hui je pense
plus orienté
sur un certain nombre de préoccupations
de nos industries
et
dans la suite de cette démarche je me
plais aussi à souligner en quoi l'action
du gouvernement s'est fondée sur un
souci de concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux et sur une démarche
participative en effet certaines des
mesures que vous nous présentez
aujourd'hui
proviennent de ce travail participatif
qui a été fait au cours des mois et
écoulés lors de toutes ces réunions lors
des Assises de la fiscalité des
entreprises
toutes les réunions dans le cadre de la
mise à plat de la fiscalité et des
différentes concertations qui ont été
établies je crois que on a là
l'illustration de ce que doit être une
politique
dynamique mais fondée sur la recherche
d'orientation consensuelle et je crois
que sur les questions d'emploi on doit
chercher cette efficacité à travers
cette volonté de consensus ce qui
conduit donc avec le pack de
responsabilité de solidarité aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de décisions vous les
avez annoncé sur la baisse tendancielle
des taux d'impôts sociétés sur la
suppression de la C3S au niveau des
impôts de production c'est une
revendication fortement mise en avant
par les entreprises le soutien
spécifique au PME avec cette allègement
de cotisation entre 1 et 1,3 SMIC qui va
profiter principalement ou en tout cas
en première part ou PME la réduction des
cotisations sociales des indépendants
le dispositif de d'évolution de la taxe
d'apprentissage bref je crois qu'il y a
aujourd'hui la manifestation d'une
claire volonté sur les questions
d'emplois pour des résultats qui vont
certainement apparaître dans le paysage
à court ou moyen terme et puis il y a
bien sûr la partie solidarité en ce qui
concerne des ménages vous l'avez
souligné avec la des cotisations
salariales là diminution d'impôts pour
ce qu'on appelle les bas de barème et un
certain nombre de mesures
complémentaires monsieur le ministre du
Budget peut-être allez-vous pouvoir nous
dire dans quelle direction ces mesures
complémentaires qui sont annoncées déjà
mais qui sont un peu
imprécis quand on compte tenu la
formulation est un peu elliptique mais
peut-être est-il déjà opportun de
préciser peut-être allez-vous pouvoir
nous le dire notamment en ce qui
concerne ce qui concerne la fiscalité
locale quelles sont les conséquences de
l'ensemble des dispositions qui sont
prises aujourd'hui et puis enfin vous
avez
cette volonté d'une maîtrise du déficit
avec la mise en oeuvre anticipée
anticipé d'un certain nombre des
économies envisagées dans le cas des 50
milliards donc incontestablement ce PLF
même si les modestes comparé à ce qu'il
y avait il y a deux ans dans ces
montants révèle néanmoins à la fois une
vigilance en ce qui concerne la maîtrise
des déficits et une claire volonté
d'action ce qui concerne notre économie
ce qui concerne la croissance et
concerne la préoccupation de l'emploi et
également du pouvoir d'achat des plus
modestes donc je ne peux pour ma part
que souligner les vertus de ces
dispositions que vous nous présentez
dans le pdfr pour autant j'ai deux ou
trois questions
peut-être un peu technique tout d'abord
monsieur le ministre du Budget
s'agissant des ajustements de crédit
je souhaitais vous interroger sur deux
points qui ont récemment été évoqués
dans la presse et pour lesquelles le
collectif ne semble pas prévoir
d'ouverture de Crédit je pense en
premier lieu au risque d'amende sur les
aides agricoles communautaires et je
pense aussi aux créations
supplémentaires d'emploi d'avenir
pourriez-vous nous préciser si les
crédits ouverts en loi de finance
initiale permettent de couvrir ses
dépenses ou à défaut
nous dire comment celle-ci devrait être
financée
un autre point technique porte sur les
décaissements liés aux investissements
d'avenir parce que on a bien noté vous
nous l'avez dit que dans les 4 milliards
d'euros d'économies supplémentaires
il est question pour environ 400
millions d'euros du rythme de
décaissement des Investissements
d'Avenir donc un rythme plus faible
quanticipé et c'est à dire que ce rythme
est piloté ou s'agit-il seulement d'un
constat bref
ne faudrait-il pas au contraire en bonne
logique accélérer ce rythme pour que
l'investissement soit dynamisé et
pourriez-vous nous donner des précisions
à ce sujet
nous revendiquons une évolution du
dispositif pour revenir à quelque chose
qui était jugé plus satisfaisant c'est
ce que nous avions déjà manifesté lors
d'adoption du PLF pour 2014 et nous
souhaitons vraiment que des réponses
soient apportées à toute les
collectivités qui attendent d'avoir des
précisions à ce sujet donc peut-être
pourriez-vous nous apporter quelques
précisions à ce sujet voilà monsieur le
Président les quelques compléments
d'explications que je souhaitais avoir
au nom de notre commission merci
beaucoup monsieur leur rapporteur
général les ministres vont donc répondre
à vos différentes questions dont je
salue la sagacité comme à l'ordinaire et
je me permets d'insister sur la dernière
c'est à dire la proposition de loi qui a
été votée à l'unanimité par le Sénat
proposition de loi présentée par le
groupe RDSE sur l'ancienne taxe locale
sur l'électricité et pour éviter le rap
dans les communes
risquaient d'être victimes de la part de
certaines formes de syndicats
d'électricité avec des incidences
budgétaires qui peuvent être extrêmement
lourdes qui je le suppose se produisent
même monsieur le ministre Argenton sur
Creuse n'est-ce pas enfin en tout cas
cela ne me semble pas impossible voilà
et donc
nous serions heureux que vous puissiez
répondre aux interventions du rapporteur
général il a évoqué les investissements
d'avenir qu'est-ce qui nous garantit
messieurs les ministres qu'on n'utilise
pas l'argent des investissements
d'avenir pour combler les insuffisances
du budget général mais quand j'ai reçu
récemment une décision dont par ailleurs
je ne conteste aucunement le bien-fondé
de virement de crédit en faveur
du budget militaire du CEA je me suis
demandé si ce n'était pas une
rectification d'enveloppes dans le cadre
des activités récurrentes de cette
organisme et qui sont indispensables à
défense nationale et à la République
mais à partir des investissements
d'avenir qui proviennent de ce que l'on
a appelé autrefois le grand emprunt qui
devait être strictement individualisée
et pertinentes
deux choses
s'agissant de la taxe communale
qui effectivement concerne aussi bien
Argenton-sur-Creuse que toutes les
communes de plus de 2000 habitants si ma
mémoire est bonne Argenton-sur-Creuse en
comprenant 5474
oui nous sommes parfaitement ouverts un
amendement qui viendrait au cours de la
discussion tenir les engagements qui
étaient à la fois les volonté qui s'est
exprimée ici la volonté qui s'est
exprimée aussi à l'Assemblée nationale
et les engagements du gouvernement donc
je crois que ça fait partie vraiment de
ce à quoi nous sommes ouverts dans la
discussion elle-même et je répondrai
juste sur un point dans les questions
très précises qui ont été posées
s'agissant des crédits inscrits sont-ils
suffisants ou non pour faire face à tel
ou tel annonce mais s'agissant des
emplois d'avenir il se trouve que comme
c'est moi qui ai mis en place budget
pour l'année 2014 dans ce domaine là ce
qui a été annoncé et parfaitement en
ligne avec les crédits inscrits au
budget pour
2014 comptabilité soit en stock soit en
flux mais la comptabilité en stock
prévoyait 150 000 emplois d'avenir en
stock au même moment ce qui rend la
possibilité de la possibilité de
renouveler un certain nombre de
d'emplois d'avenir c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre les flux et les stocks
mais le la comptabilité en stock et la
plus avantageuse du point de vue
budgétaire elle prend en compte le
maximum possible à un instant donné et
donc je sais que de ce point de vue là
les crédits nécessaires à la mise en
oeuvre de ce programme emploi d'avenir
tel qu'il a été décrit par mon
successeur sont aujourd'hui suffisants
pour le reste Christian non monsieur
Louise pour les 45 000 emplois
supplémentaires qui s'ajoutent aux 50
000 déjà annoncés on a les financements
qui sont je vais disponibles pour
l'exercice corriger si je puis dire les
150 000 sont en stock les 195.000 sont
en flux
pour le stock comme pour le flux les
crédits nécessaires très bien
quelques précisions supplémentaires
vous parlez sur un porteur général de
mesures complémentaires
oui il peut y avoir des mesures
complémentaires
comment je dirais
ce réserve qu'elle soit engagée
évidemment mais c'est pas secrétaire
d'État au budget qui va vous dire que
l'issue du travail parlementaire
pourrait conduire à dégrader le solde
mais vous avez évoqué la fiscalité
locale et donc j'imagine que vous pensez
à la taxe d'habitation et
aux réductions ou exonérations pour
certaines catégories notamment les
personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées voir les gens qui ont des
faibles revenus
le gouvernement sera attentif et je
crois pouvoir dire assez réceptif à des
propositions qui pourraient conduire à
ce que par exemple une idée mais peut y
en avoir d'autres ceux qui ont été
exonérés une année soit exonéré l'année
suivante même s'il ne remplissent plus
forcément les critères en raison du
augmentation de leur revenu fiscal de
référence qui serait lié parfois à
d'autres phénomènes on sait qu'il y a un
certain nombre de
de revenus qui vont être réintégrés dans
le revenu fiscal de référence donc ça
peut être une piste mais là encore une
piste qui vaudrait pour cette année mais
à laquelle j'invite que l'ensemble du
parlementaires puissent travailler sur
une mesure là encore plus durable
concernant votre question sur les aides
agricoles ou un contentieux avec la
Commission semble s'ouvrir ou se durcir
on se concrétiser malheureusement
chaque Chaudé craint l'eau froide des
contentieux
bruxellois nous ont coûté et nous coûte
encore très cher
très cher par les OPCVM par exemple
c'est plusieurs milliards
que d'ailleurs cette majorité assume par
rapport à des décisions des non
décisions antérieures évitons les
polémiques mais concernant le sujet que
vous évoquez il est réel il y a
actuellement une discussion entre la
France et la commission sur le volume de
ce qui pourrait être
réclamé en termes de retour
sur entretenu d'ailleurs très récemment
avec le ministre de l'Agriculture
l'écart d'interprétation est très très
massif entre ce que la France pourrait
reconnaître comme ayant été des mesures
à corriger et à rembourser et puis ce
qui estime dans un premier temps la
commission s'agit d'avoir recensé les
parties des terres donnant lieu à des à
des aides uniquement sur des travaux
cartographiques
il y a là une vraiment une un travail
actuellement
qui pourrait conduire un contentieux
significatif mais en ce qui concerne le
montant définitif il n'est pas
communiqué l'aléa est prise en compte il
n'y a d'ailleurs pas d'annulation dans
le projet de loi de finance rectif sur
le sur le sur la ligne concernée de même
mais la réponse a été faite sur les
emplois d'avenir
le coût des emplois d'avenir
supplémentaires d'abord nous
concernerait qu'une partie de l'année
puisque par définition nous sommes au
mois de juin tout ça se met en oeuvre
donc le coût paraît effectivement
largement anticipé il y a d'ailleurs là
aussi sur cette ligne aucune annulation
de crédit budgétaire
sur votre question sur le Pia
nous avons anticipé 400 milliards
millions pardon de dépenses en moins
pourquoi parce que c'est une
marronnier tous les ans sur le pays a
compte tenu de la nature des projets je
vais venir à la questionnement du
président Marini
tous les ans il y a une sous-exécution
d'un certain nombre de projets et
s'agit-il ou non de des budgétisation
appelant un chat un chat
le programme investissements d'avenir
répond à ce nombre de critères précis et
gérer par des gens qui veillent
scrupuleusement à ce que nous rentrions
dans la doctrine que ces données que
nous sommes donnés pour que l'on puisse
inclure des projets dans les
investissements d'avenir
parfois comme dans toute évaluation les
frontières sont tenues nous
reconnaissons le s'agissant de
programmes militaire il y a aussi des
impacts de la recherche y compris dans
des secteurs civils
il est parfois assez compliqué de faire
la part des choses mais
là encore soyons clairs
la loi de programmation militaire
contient un article qui dit qu'en cas de
non-réalisation d'un certain nombre de
crédit ne serait pas mise en place
les programmes d'investissement d'avenir
pourrait consacrer 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires à des opérations
plus centrée sur la défense nous
inscrivons
250 millions à ce titre dès cette loi de
finances rectificative il n'y aura un
complément prévu dans le texte Haddock
le moment venu et donc nous mettons en
oeuvre cette clause de sauvegarde je
sais pas si on peut l'appeler comme ça
de la loi de programmation militaire ce
qui n'exonère pas la dépense la défense
pardon de veiller à ses dépenses y
compris ces dépenses récurrentes de
fonctionnement vous observerez
d'ailleurs que la défense est concernée
aussi dans le milliard d'annulations de
crédit
à hauteur de 250 millions sur la réserve
de précaution et d'une centaine de
millions non pardon c'est le contraire
de 25 nous ayons au-delà de la réserve
et de 100 millions dans la réserve de
précaution
toujours est-il qu'il faut rester
prudent c'est pas votre commission que
j'apprendrai que les Opex par exemple
représentent régulièrement et tous les
ans des besoins supplémentaires que nous
cherchons et que nous trouvons la
plupart du temps dans la réserve de
précaution mais à chaque jour suffit sa
peine nous aurons l'occasion de voir ça
en fin d'année merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre de ces réponses qui sont en
effet fort précises qui ne contourne pas
les questions alors j'ai aidé demande de
parole de Monsieur Doliger monsieur
Dallier madame Nicole brick monsieur
Adnot monsieur café
c'est tout pour l'instant
alors la parole est à monsieur le
président
Eric Doliger merci président
effectivement je vais interroger les
ministres on aborde dans la présentation
il n'y a pas de faille on a vraiment le
sentiment qui a pas de problème
particulier et d'être peut-être un peu
dans une bulle dans cette salle et que
dehors il y a pas de problème et
d'ailleurs le Rapporteur général a
encore en Jolivet la présentation dans
son propos préliminaire et la même été
jusqu'à dire qu'en 2012 dans le PFR de
2012 on avait mis en place un certain
nombre de mesures en matière d'emplois
et de croissance bon je sais pas si on a
ressenti les effets mais enfin il a
quand même apporté une analyse de 2012
dont j'ai peut-être pas tout à fait
ressenti les mêmes effets que lui alors
quelques réflexions
d'abord vous nous avez dit aussi
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre Michel Sapin que le Président
de la République qui avait déjà annoncé
depuis un certain nombre de mois un
certain nombre de mesures dans le cadre
de la sécurité sociale et que il avait
tenu ses mesures moi je dirais c'est pas
parce que le Président de la République
a lancé en janvier des mesures qui les
suit toujours on va parler des
collectivités donc je suis prouve bien
que les mesures on peut les annoncer et
qu'on peut ne pas toujours les appliquer
alors moi ce que j'aimerais c'est sur le
tableau qui a été présenté qui est très
intéressant la page 27 et que Monsieur
le Ministre Sapin a présenté sur la mise
en oeuvre des mesures on a toute une
série 2014 jusqu'à 2017 de réduction
d'allègement et de cette baisse etc donc
on a un tableau extrêmement sympathique
sur la durée ce que je voudrais savoir
c'est si on s'engage
à tenir ce tableau ou est-ce que c'est
un tableau indicatif ou est-ce que
vraiment vous pensez et bien qu'on
retrouvera en 2017 l'abaissement prog du
taux de Liège ramené à 28% ou est-ce
qu'on ne sera pas obligé de le décaler
dans le temps parce que présenter un
tableau de cette manière ça donne le
sentiment que bon il y a pas de souci
particulier à se faire que tout va
s'arranger
tout à l'heure le ministre a dit aussi
tout cela est compréhensible pour les
chefs d'entreprise or j'ai le sentiment
que les entreprises actuellement ont
quelques positions par rapport au Pacte
des responsabilités qui semblent montrer
qui ne sont peut-être pas tout à fait en
sécurité par rapport aux annonces qui
ont été faites donc par rapport
éventuellement à ce tableau et d'autres
annonces est-ce qu'il y a un tableau qui
a été oublié d'être mis qui serait mise
en oeuvre des mesures nouvelles mais en
matière de hausse s'il y en a pas très
bien vous nous le confirmez et à ce
moment-là vous engagez à ce qui en est
pas serait quand même intéressant parce
que de montrer que les baisses c'est
bien alors il y a quelque chose
une réflexion à laquelle je n'arrive pas
à me faire que vous avez refaites
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre et que
vous aviez faite il y a 8 jours devant
nous c'est de dire il y a deux ans ou
trois ans on avait un déficit de 142
milliards et alors là je brode mais
grâce à des mesures décidées par des
cerveaux donc intelligentes maintenant
on n'est plus qu'à 70 milliards de
déficit donc 142 à 70 est-ce que la
différence est pas 70 milliards à peu de
choses près qui sont des hausses
d'impôts donc si c'est le moyen
d'arriver à faire baisser le déficit que
d'augmenter les impôts c'est quand même
quelque peu inquiétant dans la méthode
parce qu'on est tous en capacité de le
faire et à la limite on pourrait ramener
le déficit à zéro il suffit d'augmenter
de 70 milliards les impôts cette année
donc c'est un raisonnement bien sûr un
peu simpliste qui n'est pas fait pour
les cerveaux intelligents mais enfin moi
pour pour moi j'ai réfléchi à cet humble
au niveau
que vous souhaitez faire je rappelle
quand même qu'il y en a 11,5 sur les
collectivités donc on le redit
régulièrement ce que j'aimerais savoir
c'est si sur la période puisque en fait
2014 2017 est-ce qu'il n'y aura plus
de
d'ajouts supplémentaires à séance
milliards et demi qui viennent je pense
ajouter en partie au milliards et demi
plus le milliard et demi etc quand on a
déjà vu passer dans des précédentes donc
est-ce que tout cela est figé ou alors
si ça n'est pas figé je pense que les
tableaux prospectifs il faut vraiment
marquer sous réserve etc parce que là ça
nous est présenté comme étant à peu près
des certitudes au moins dans le discours
puis dernier point j'aurais voulu le
dire à Michel Sapin j'étais heureux
d'apprendre qui allait l'électricité à
Argenton-sur-Creuse ce qui puisque s'il
va bénéficier de la taxe c'est donc il a
bien l'électricité c'est la question que
je me posais mais je lui passerai le
message non mais c'est une plaisanterie
entre nous parce que je le connais
suffisamment en région Centre pour
savoir quel est son état d'esprit sur le
sujet et bien sûr
cette taxe cette taxe on va la rétablir
intelligemment dans sa répartition parce
que c'est insupportable pour nos
communes au niveau local et il est
important qu'on soit en capacité de leur
redonner quelques moyens
d'investissement merci beaucoup Eric
deliger qui nous montre que apparemment
elle est dispositions proposées sont
moins consensuelles que nous semblait le
croire notre cher à porteur général
alors Monsieur Philippe d'Allier
merci monsieur le Président ma question
concerne un secteur d'activité important
pour l'économie en cela qu'il est non
délocalisable et qu'il est porteur d'un
potentiel de croissance important si
tentait que ce secteur se porte bien ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait le cas
aujourd'hui puisque je veux parler du
logement les chiffres de mise en
chantier pour 2013 ont été très mauvais
un peu plus de 320 000 on était à
100.000 de plus deux ans auparavant et
pour 2014 les choses se présentent à peu
près aussi mal si ce n'est plus mal et
certains font porter la responsabilité
de cette situation à la loi alur qui est
loin d'avoir donné tous ses effets
puisque beaucoup de dispositifs ne sont
pas encore entrés en application
certains appellent au détricotage de la
loi j'ai entendu le ministre tous les
cas le porte-parole du gouvernement
d'hier qu'il n'en est pas question mais
on parle aussi peut-être de nouvelles
mesures fiscales pour essayer
de relancer le secteur et le dispositif
du flot semble ne pas donner les
résultats attendus on parle de 30000
l'an dernier contre 40 000 espérés donc
est-ce que ce collectif n'aurait pas été
l'occasion sans attendre la loi de
finances initiale pour 2015 de donner un
coup de pouce à secteur parce que 0,1 ou
0,2 point de croissance avec une bonne
relance dans le secteur du logement à
mon avis c'est quelque chose que l'on
peut essayer de tenter alors une
question également sur les crédits de la
mission égalité les territoires
logements et villes on a une annulation
de crédit de 59 millions un peu plus de
59 millions et si je me reporte à au
motif des annulations en dessous le
tableau on lit annulation de crédit de
paiement par une modulation du rythme
des dépenses du programme
bon j'imagine que ce n'est pas la
dépense de guichet que correspond les
aides au logement qui est visé mais bien
évidemment les aides de l'État pour
aussi être la construction on a le
sentiment en lisant cela que bon ben
voilà la conjoncture est atome et donc
on s'y adapte et on réduit les crédits
on en a eu un certain ce qui ne me
semble peut-être pas la meilleure
manière de relancer le secteur
d'activité en question
et je précise également que ce n'est pas
seulement l'accession à la propriété qui
est touché puisque même les mises en
chantier concernant le logement social
ont l'air de piquer du nez donc monsieur
le ministre est-ce que vous ne ratez pas
une bonne occasion au travers de ce
collectif d'essayer de rectifier un
certain nombre de choses pour relancer
le secteur d'activité
merci beaucoup à Philippe d'allier à
présent la parole est à Nicole brique
oui
voilà donc
un jugement général sur ce projet de loi
de finance rectificative qui est fort
heureusement du reste dans la continuité
des choix engagés en novembre 2012 et
dans l'accélération souhaitée par le
Président de la République en début
d'année
et il fait office de loi de finance
rectificative puisque comme son nom
l'indique il rectifie vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre en fonction de
l'exécution budgétaire des plus-values
et des moins-values et évidemment il
engage un programme d'économie et l'État
il prend sa part une fois encore à
hauteur d'un milliard 6 donc il fait
vraiment son office parce que il faut
absolument qu'on assainisse les finances
publiques en même temps qu'on soutienne
la croissance on ne remet pas du tout en
cause alors moi j'ai un seul petit
problème
concernant l'impôt sur les sociétés et
chez moi il est pas nouveau
j'ai toujours défendu l'idée que nous
avions des taux faciaux trop élevés et
donc vous prolongez la surtaxe de
l'impôt sur les sociétés donc dont vous
pouvez peut-être nous dire au passage
parce que je me souviens pas qu'elle en
est le produit comment se passe cette
exécution c'est intéressant de le savoir
maintenant et de vous la prolonger donc
d'un an au moment où
des partenaires de la zone euro qui ont
fait de la compétitivité à l'exportation
un moteur essentiel de leur retour à
bonne fortune et qui en même temps joue
leur carte d'attractivité du territoire
je pense à l'Italie qui a engagé une
baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés à
hauteur de 5 points
et à l'Espagne qui s'apprête à le faire
et qui sont des partenaires importants
dans la zone euro donc
moi je pense que ce n'est pas un très
bon signal donné aux entreprises le pack
de compétitivité et le pack de
responsabilité c'est quand même
s'engager dans un pacte de confiance
avec les entreprises et ça va un peu à
contre-courant de d'autres partenaires
de la zone euro voilà donc je voulais
vous faire cette réflexion
je le dis je suis là j'ai toujours été
en continuité sur ce sujet j'ai toujours
pensé que notamment vers le haut on
était beaucoup trop élevés il y a un
effet psychologique qui n'est pas bon
pour pour la confiance tant des
investisseurs étrangers que
des entreprises françaises à l'étranger
voilà
merci
Nicole brick parole est à Philippe non
merci monsieur le Président oui monsieur
le ministre moi j'ai cherché partout
dans le document une provision
supplémentaire pour le RSA et je l'ai
pas trouvé or j'ai lu récemment un texte
qui vient du ministère
de la Santé et qui dit que
68% des gens qui pourraient bénéficier
du RSA ne l'ont pas demandé
alors comme moi je suis un adepte de la
règle de trois ça vous étonnera pas je
me dis si chez nous
32% représente 45 millions
68% de plus vont représenter combien et
je n'ai pas trouvé chez vous la
provision
et donc je me demande comment vous allez
faire parce que c'est donc le ministère
qui dit allez-y consommer il n'y a pas
assez de gens qui demandent le RSA 68 %
des ayants droits ne le demande pas et
donc je voudrais savoir comment vous
allez financer ça
une question claire n'est-ce pas et qui
montre permettez-moi de le dire que les
présidentes conseils généraux nous sont
bien utiles
pour apprécier la réalité des choses
notamment dans le domaine de la cohésion
sociale alors c'est Jean-Pierre café
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais commencer en remercier en les
les ministres de nous avoir présenté les
deux textes en fait à la fois le
collectif budgétaire le PLF mais en même
temps d'avoir retracé les grandes
dispositions du PLFSS que nous
examinerons ici pour avis bien
évidemment car ces deux textes sont dans
mon esprit indissociable et ici sont
indissociables c'est que ils mettent en
œuvre à la fois le pack de solidarité
mais également le pack de responsabilité
et donc je crois que c'est de bonne
politique et je voudrais en remercier le
terminus d'avoir d'ores et déjà dans
deux collectifs à la fois un collectif
budgétaire mais aussi un collectif à
venir sur la sécurité sociale d'avoir je
dirais inscrit dans le marbre les
mesures du pacte de responsabilité
et donc c'est une anticipation je crois
qui jouera probablement sur le
comportement de tes entreprises et de ce
point de vue là c'est une bonne chose de
ne pas avoir attendu à la fois les lois
de finance initiales les lois de finance
initiale également de sécurité sociale
cela étant dit j'aurais deux questions
la première question porte en fait sur
les recettes quand on regarde l'état a
on s'aperçoit que
la correction sur les recettes les
recettes brutes portent à peu près sur
un montant de 10 milliards d'euros bon
compte tenu des remboursements et des
grèvements
on en a plus que 5 ma question est la
suivante certes on avait constaté des
moins-values extrêmement importantes en
2013 entre l'exécution et la LFI à
hauteur de 15 milliards si ma mémoire
est bonne
est-ce que les 10 milliards de
correction sur les recettes sur les
recettes pour 2014 bien entendu
procède en quelque sorte d'un rebasage
c'est à dire est-ce que c'est le
rebazage en fait des moins-values qui
ont été constatés en 2013
et ma seconde question porte sur les
annulations de crédit je vois qu'il y en
a 350 millions sur la défense dont 250
au-delà de la réserve est-ce que nous
pourrions avoir quelques précisions sur
la nature de ces économies faites sur le
ministère de la Défense
merci beaucoup à Jean-Pierre cafe est-ce
que d'autres collègues souhaitent
s'exprimer alors je vois monsieur Chiron
monsieur Dominati y a-t-il d'autres
demandes de parole c'est tout alors
Monsieur Jacques Chiron oui monsieur le
monsieur le ministre je vais avoir
quelques petites précisions sur
sur les mesures concernant le logement
et particulièrement le logement social
je vois qu'il y aurait un gel pendant de
l'évolution des barèmes durant une
période jusqu'en 2015 bien j'ai dans le
texte que j'essaie de détailler en page
125 je m'aperçois qu'il y aurait aussi
un certain nombre de paramètres de
calcul forfaitaires sur l'indexation
donc c'est ce que ça signifie que les
bailleurs sociaux verraient leur indice
de majoration du loyer qui serait aussi
je dirais bloqué ce qui me serait pas ce
qui serait pas je dirais
ce qui peut être acceptable dans la
situation actuelle quand on regarde le
premier trimestre 2014 l'indice est à
0,6 et là une tendance à la baisse
et quand on regarde on constate que le
coût de la construction parallèle au
loyer est devenu négatif
-
74% puis moins de 18 dans les appels
d'offres que l'on fait aujourd'hui ça me
permettra de répondre à notre collègue
allié on s'aperçoit que on a une baisse
de moins 10% du coût de la construction
qui est due à la fois à une baisse des
entreprises du coût de l'entreprise mais
aussi à une baisse du coût des matériaux
donc je dirais si c'est en parallèle ça
permettrait en effet à locataire de ne
pas subir de hausse de loyer durant
l'année qui vient ça peut être ça c'est
déjà fait c'était président d'un
organisme de
logements sociaux et on l'a fait
plusieurs fois et ça peut être
acceptable je pense et ça permettrait de
pas pénaliser
les les locataires de logements sociaux
je dirais un autre collègue
d'allier il se plaint de la baisse de
j'étais acteur pendant 20 ans dans le
logement social
quand on construit un logement c'est 30
mois entre la chair la charge du foncier
rechercher un foncier faire un projet le
bâtir 30 mois avant le début de la
construction c'est la moyenne donc si je
prends 2013 et je remonte à 30 mois
permettez-moi de vous dire on retombe en
2010 et j'espère en effet que des
mesures seront prises assez rapidement
pour être plus rapide que les 30 mois
mais c'est ça la réalité du logement
enfin en ce qui me concerne je l'ai vécu
pendant 20 ans
alors mes chers collègues donc voilà une
sorte de question de paternité qui est
posée ce sont parfois des sujets très
délicats les questions de paternité
alors la parole est à philippe Dominati
moi monsieur le Président je voudrais
retenir de ce correctif budgétaire le
fait que vous avez souligné c'est que le
solde du déficit de l'État s'accroît de
1 milliard et en cela c'est le chiffre
important c'est une réelle déception
parce que pour autant un certain nombre
de nouvelles auraient pu être
satisfaisante il y a je dirais des
bonnes surprises des recettes plus
importantes sur la fraude fiscale par
exemple de l'ordre de 1 milliard des
charges moins importantes sur l'intérêt
de la dette de l'ordre de 1 milliard 800
millions donc je dirais il y avait quand
même matière à faire en sorte qu'il y
ait un signal
sur le plan international le plan
européen et puis surtout pour la
confiance de l'économie parce que les
tableaux qui nous entraînent jusqu'en
2017 moi je n'ai pas l'optimiste d'un
certain nombre de mes collègues de
pensent que de penser que c'est qu'elle
est dans le marbre je voudrais rappeler
que normalement le rendez-vous qui avait
été pris à l'été de cette année c'était
le rendez-vous de la grande réforme
fiscale de annoncé par l'ancien Premier
ministre au mois de novembre et nous
attendions pour l'été les grandes
réformes fiscales je constate
qu'effectivement plus personne n'en
parle aujourd'hui il y a que quelques
mois que cela s'est produit si moi sept
mois et je n'ai entendu aucun des
ministres même ceux qui étaient au
gouvernement précédent je parle du
ministre du Travail parce qu'on parlait
travail et emplois
ok il y a eu des changements notamment
contenu de je dirais des déceptions qui
ont été provoquées dans la nature de la
conduite des affaires économiques en
2013 donc on parle pas de réforme
fiscale et par contre parmi les bonnes
nouvelles ou peut-être dans
l'appréciation que l'on peut en tirer
c'est la constatation des moins-values
sur les recettes de l'ordre de 5
milliards alors en net comme le dit
Jean-Pierre cafe ça pourrait être 10 et
il y a une conséquence et ce qui serait
intéressant c'est de savoir quel est
justement lorsque un gouvernement
annonce une pression fiscale accrue
puisque je vous rappelle que pour le
précédent gouvernement la stabilisation
devait intervenir qu'en 2015 de la
pression fiscale finalement on
s'aperçoit que presque immédiatement les
recettes ne sont pas au rendez-vous pour
moi ça me surprend pas je dirais une
vision libérale de l'économie dans un
certain nombre de pays ont démontré que
la pression fiscale n'est plus
supportable par les agents de l'économie
au delà d'un certain seuil et que c'est
devient totalement inutile mais perdre 5
milliards on a aussi peu de temps dans
les recettes fiscales pouvez-vous nous
dire comment vous avez Ann oncé une
augmentation de la pression fiscale et
ce taux ce taux de non recouvrement ce
serait intéressant de savoir je dirais
recette par recette parce que la
pression fiscale a accrue brutalement au
cours des deux dernières années par
exemple sur l'impôt sur le revenu et
finalement il manque 5 milliards alors
ça ça serait un ratio qui serait
intéressant je dirais dans le débat à
venir et c'était un peu le sens de ma
question monsieur le président
merci beaucoup à philippe Dominati donc
ainsi et close la liste des intervenants
et monsieur le ministre va s'efforcer de
répondre aux uns et aux autres avec la
précision qui est toujours la sienne
qui essaie qui n'essaye d'avoir
beaucoup de questions évidemment toutes
légitime
essayer de
reprendre d'abord le thème
on présente un programme sur trois ans
voire même sur quatre ans le fameux
tableau quel est le degré d'engagement
des uns des autres gouvernement tenter
là encore d'avoir une certaine forme
d'équilibre 1 ces mesures ont été
François Marc le rappel rappelait tout à
l'heure souvent discuter dans un certain
nombre de concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux notamment les
assises de fiscalité des entreprises
qui différents groupes de travail des
rencontres en géométrie variable et
multiples donc elles sont à la assez
largement connus des partenaires sociaux
ceci ne suffit pas
elles ont été clairement inscrites de la
trajectoire des finances publiques
notamment dans le programme de stabilité
ça ne suffit pas
elles seront inscrites et rappelées dans
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques tri annuelles que vous
examinerez que nous vous proposerons
d'examiner à l'automne
donc il y a la clairement un engagement
dans le temps et dans la durée
reste une fois qu'on a posé le cadre qui
me semble quand même maintenant très
largement connu
à décliner de façon opérationnelle
chacune des mesures
on a le choix
premièrement on aurait pu attendre
indépendamment de la mesure fiscale qui
a été largement évoquée sur les autres
mesures
on aurait pu attendre la loi de finances
initiale 2015 ou le PLFSS 2015
nous anticipons
certains auraient suggéré que nous
inscrivions l'ensemble des mesures
jusqu'en 2017
nous pensons que dans un pacte il y a le
dévaluer et de progresser
en validant chacune des étapes
pour voir si chacun a respecté au mieux
compte tenu d'une conjoncture mais pas
toujours mettre de tout
en respectant les engagements des uns
des autres donc le gouvernement a décidé
ce que nous vous proposons d'inscrire
les mesures 2014 il y en a peu toutes
les mesures de 2015 nous aurions pu
attendre et par contre dans le courant
de l'année 2015 on évaluant la
réactivité des choses du monde
économique de l'emploi des
investissements de la croissance il y
aura peut-être lieu d'anticiper ou de
retarder tel ou telle mesure mais nous
inscrivons pas dans cette a priori nous
avons un cadre pluriannuel décliné sur
l'ensemble des mesures il est pas
chiffré dans ce document il est il a été
assez largement chiffré j'en profite
pour dire à Nicole brick que la surtaxis
dont il est question rapporte autour de
2,5 milliards d'euros
sachant que faut toujours être prudent
par rapport aux chiffres et des chiffres
bruts et des chiffres nets chacun sait
que les allègements de cotisations
sociales
engendre à peu près mécaniquement une
augmentation de l'impôt sur les sociétés
ou sur le revenu donc il faut parfois
certains ne parlent que du chiffrage
brut d'autres
déduisent les retours d'impôts que l'on
peut attendre qui sont pas d'ailleurs
mécaniquement de 33% comme on pourrait
le penser qui sont parfois inférieurs
enfin tout ça résulte de travaux à ces
techniques que je vous épargne et donc
voilà quel est le choix de l'inscription
dans le temps des mesures et de leur
déclinaison opérationnelle donc je crois
qu'il faut vraiment comprendre que c'est
un engagement très fort qui s'étale sur
trois ans mais qui
on va se cacher derrière notre petit
doigt certains partenaires sociaux nous
l'ont demandé de ne pas tout écrire tout
de suite en disant regardons quand même
comment tout ça réagit et puis on au fil
du temps on déclinera les mesures elles
sont connues elles sont quantifiées
vous aurez d'ici une semaine
puisque quand c'est les ministres
examinera le 28 juin prochain le
plfssrss et vous en aurez les détails
figurent déjà assez largement dans tous
les documents qui vous ont été transmis
ou qui ont été diffusés d'ailleurs les
caisses de sécurité sociale s'agissant
de cotisations sociales ont été
destinataires des avant-projets
puisqu'ils ont à rendre un avis
beaucoup de questions étaient posées
donc par sénateur de Ligier auquel je
viens en grande partie de répondre
les économies sur les collectivités
locales oui elles sont connues il y
aura-t-il des hausses par rapport à des
baisses c'est ce que vous avez suggéré
ou gouvernement n'a pas l'intention
d'augmenter
toute forme de fiscalité bon maintenant
encore une fois ça a été dit ça a été
annoncé vous ne trouverez rien dans ce
texte qui augmente de la fiscalité vous
ne trouverez rien dans les cartons qui
augmentent des des fiscalités et là
encore il faut être tout à fait clair et
transparent
il y a certaines formes de fiscalité qui
ont été inscrites dans le temps
notamment en fin d'année dernière c'est
la fiscalité environnementale
elle était inscrite pour trois ans et
quand vous êtes détecteur attentif des
rapports de vos rapporteurs généraux
pas franchement lu complètement celui de
François mais il se trouve que j'avais
signé le mien lorsque j'étais à
l'Assemblée vous savez qu'il y a une
montée en puissance de la fiscalité de
la contribution qui m'a énergie il faut
le se le dire très clairement elle est
destinée à financer la montée en
puissance du cice
pour le financer pour petite partie
sachant que nous aurons l'occasion
d'ailleurs d'en reparler le cice est
bien inscrit dans le temps c'est la
terre d'Olivier vous vous posiez la
question l'échelle d'entreprise sont en
train de le percevoir
son rendent compte il y a finalement
savais pas que c'était ça il y a quand
même beaucoup d'étonnement je vous
rappelle qu'il a été calculé sur la base
de 4% de la masse salariale vous
connaissez tout ça mais que l'année
prochaine ce sera six pour cent
donc ça va être la moitié en plus la
situation toute chose égale par ailleurs
ce sera la moitié en plus pour les
entreprises et que
bon il y aura peut-être quelques menus
aménagements mais vraiment très très
menu des ajustements très techniques
elles attendront les rapports
d'évaluation tout ça est destiné
effectivement s'inscrire dans la durée
sur le logement beaucoup de questions
portées sur ce secteur du logement elle
nous interpelle tous
moi je vais répondre avec beaucoup
d'humilité sur la question du logement
en tenant compte de la remarque qui a
été fait tout à l'heure sur la Sicile
enfin bon je vais pas me lancer dans un
débat sur lequel je viens de vous dire
que je n'étais pas spécialiste mais mais
j'observe j'observe
monsieur sénateur que beaucoup de
mesures ont été prises en direction du
logement beaucoup plus de 5 milliards
ont été engagés 2012 dans le secteur du
logement je vous rappelle la TVA 5,5 %
sur les travaux de rénovation thermique
je vous rappelle l'abaissement
l'abaissement du seuil de TVA sur le
logement social à
5,5%. je vous rappelle la réforme des
plus-values des valeurs immobilières en
raccourcissant la durée de ces
plus-values d'une mesure d'ailleurs que
la droite avait prise en son temps qui
avait provoqué blocage du marché
immobilier et sur laquelle nous sommes
revenus je vous rappelle les dispositifs
fiscaux et de TVA ou de taxes foncières
sur le logement intermédiaire
s'il suffisait de prendre des mesures
fiscales ou budgétaires pour décoincer
le secteur du logement j'ai envie de
dire vous aurez ou en tout cas nous
aurons l'occasion d'en mesurer les
effets s'il y a des effets retards
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
dispositions concernant la misée de
disposition du foncier que nous
souhaitons d'ailleurs accélérer
puisque dans certains secteurs c'est
l'indisponibilité de foncier qui retarde
la construction c'est pas vrai dans tous
les secteurs géographiques je veux dire
mais dans un certain secteur c'est vrai
et si l'État avec un certain nombre de
si bien peu y apporter de la fluidité
l'État le fera d'ailleurs je conclus sur
ce sujet en disant que dans le PLF 2015
ou gouvernement vous proposera un
certain nombre de choses
oui non mais
beaucoup de choses ont été mises en
place il y a des effets dans le temps ça
veut pas dire d'ailleurs je répète si
les décisions budgétaires n'étant pas
spécialiste pardon de le dire une
troisième fois je suis quand même me
permettre de penser qu'on sait qu'il y a
seulement d'effet d'aubaine qui a
certainement deux mesures qui se
retrouvent parfois pas forcément
là où il devrait se trouver parfois plus
chez le propriétaire ou chez
l'entreprise que chez le l'organisme
bailleur ou ou chez le locataire il y a
quand même dans notre pays qui est un
des pays où on accompagne le plus la
construction de logements mais où le
prix du logement est l'un des plus cher
ce qui est d'ailleurs un grave handicap
sur la compétitivité il y a quand même à
se poser à ce type de questions et où le
patrimoine
immobilier des particuliers et le plus
important
voilà
me permet de faire un constat donc je
crois que la réponse est probablement
moins simpliste que ce qui a pu être
sous-entendu par certains d'entre vous
c'est un nom parle du RSA je pense que
vous parlez du RSA activité qui est sous
demandé
non pas le RSA socle n'ont pas que que
nous ignorions cette question
gouvernement travaille actuellement
réfléchir en tout cas déjà et travaille
parce que quand on quand on réfléchit
c'est déjà une forme de travail sur la
mise en cohérence des dispositifs RSA
activités et prime pour l'emploi c'est
pas un secret le député 6 rue a commis
un rapport fort intéressant sur le sujet
n'est pas impossible que dans un avenir
plus ou moins lointain nous puissions
reprendre un certain nombre de ces
propositions
sénateur café a souligné le lien entre
les deux textes c'est effectivement une
cohérence que Michel Sapin a mis
parfaitement en évitant sur son propos
concernant les recettes
le
rebasage qui a été fait consiste à
prendre comme référence la loi de
finance rectificative de fin d'année
et donc ce qui a été fait en 2014 prend
en compte la totalité de la moins-value
de la fin de l'année 2013
et donc vous trouvez 15 milliards par
rapport à la LFI 2013 mais vous retombez
sur les bons chiffres c'est à dire 5
milliards si vous prenez comme référence
la LF R de fin d'année 2013 et ils sont
liés essentiellement à l'effet base et à
une révision de l'élasticité tout ça est
un peu technique mais effectivement
important en termes d'effets cumulés
faut pas négliger
l'effet de l'élasticité et
sur l'analyse des différents impôts
trouverez dans l'exposé des motifs je
crois son nombre de points sur l'impôt
sur le revenu l'impôt sur les sociétés
la TVA
bon on est encore un peu tôt dans
l'année pour regarder précisément ce qui
se passe en 2014
pas de signe de mouvement massif annoncé
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
puisque on taper à se revoir assez
souvent avant la fin du mois de juillet
je termine en espérant d'avoir oublié
aucune des questions sur les remarques
du sénateur
Dominati qui dit le déficit se dégrade
tout dépend de la référence que l'on
prend mais mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs c'est
il y a un objectif qui est fixé dans une
loi de finances initiale c'est objectif
on nous dit parfois qu'il est trop
ambitieux
et quand on nous l'atteint pas on parle
de dérapage
ne pas atteindre l'objectif
ça veut pas dire forcément qu'on a été
complètement nul
surtout si on a quand même réduit
substantiellement le déficit je fais
parfois un parallèle
oser mais que je peux me permettre vu ma
rondeur c'est comme quand on fait un
régime prévoyez de perdre 10 kilos et
que vous en perdez que 8 vous dites
c'est quand même 8 kg de perdu quoi hein
vous allez pas dire j'ai dérapé parce
que j'aurais dû en perdre deux de plus
en matière de réduction des déficits
pardon de l'utiliser une métaphore qui
comme toutes métaphore a toujours son
travers mais on parle de dérapage
lorsque l'on réduit un déficit moins que
ce qu'on en avait prévu de le réduire on
l'a quand même réduit et là on la réduit
d'exécution exécution par on prévoit de
le réduire de 3 milliards d'euros bon
alors on verra l'arrivée peut-être qu'on
aura réduit que de deux et demi
peut-être qu'on leur a réduit de 4 ou de
on est faut être modeste bravo prévision
quelqu'un interrogé tout à l'heure sur
l'effet de l'inflation pardon je crois
d'abord répondu je crois que c'était le
président
sur l'inflation a priori on devrait
penser que les nuls sur l'inflation
puisqu'ils je dis a priori en tout cas
sur le solde
nominal pourquoi parce que il y a des
dépenses qui augmentent moins vite que
ce qu'on aurait pu attendre et puis il y
a des recettes qui aussi augmentent
moins vite que ce qu'on a pu attendre a
priori on pourrait penser que l'effet
nul sur le déficit structurel
la chose n'est pas la même puisque vous
savez que l'évolution de la dépense
prend en compte le prévisionnel et que
dans ce prévisionnel l'inflation est
évidemment un facteur
déterminant donc voilà encore j'aurais
beaucoup d'humilité les spécialistes
nous disent qu'effectivement un peu plus
d'inflation ne nuirait pas la banque
centrale
a pris des mesures dans ce sens et nous
verrons bien qu'elles seront les
évolutions
voilà Mesdames Messieurs ou les
sénateurs ce président des éléments de
réponse que je suis en mesure à ce stade
de vous fournir en vous donnant
vous disant notre disponibilités pour
avoir un échange et un travail régulier
et fructueux avec votre commission et
bien c'est très certainement ce qui va
se poursuivre monsieur le ministre sans
doute aurons-nous encore des des
discussions sur le thème de la bouteille
à moitié pleine ou à moitié vide et
voilà chacun peut avoir son angle de vue
bien entendu et rappelons quand même que
comme la rappeler philippe Dominati il y
a bien des recettes supplémentaires mais
que ces recettes supplémentaires sont
aussitôt utilisés pour faire des
dépenses supplémentaires même si la
dépense et le réaménagement
sympathique pour certaines catégories de
contribuables du bas du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est quand même
bien d'une réalité mais
chers collègues nous avons évoqué ces
sujets chacun peut avoir ses arguments
et sa vue des choses en tout cas ce
débat aura vraiment permis d'expliciter
pour tous les présents et pour ceux qui
nous ont écouté la présentation de ce
collectif budgétaire merci mes chers
collègues et la séance élevé
voilà pour cette audition consacrée aux
collectif budgétaires nous y reviendrons
plus largement avec nos invités à 19h
dans 24 heures Sénat le journal tout de
suite la suite de vos programmes sur
Public Sénat et à tout à l'heure 19h